I had never gone through anything
serious like this but like I I went
paralyzed my whole left the whole right
side of my body and um
even like even partial like temporary
facial paralysis
um I was now damaged goods
um
and I got dropped from I was biggest
catalog selling artist I I ended up
having to be dropped by my record label
I remember I was dropped by my agency
and I learned how horrible this business
can be
um when you don't mean anything and you
can't deliver if you don't have
something to give people they don't need
you anymore they don't need you and
that's it's all yeah it's all very
superficial take you have to be tough to
weather this business you know and
people people mistake that my kindness
is weakness and my kindness to me is
King because
you know it's easy to be someone like
the guy the British guy I sat next to
you and left me
but it's it's another it's really it's
really it takes love it takes patience
it takes
stick to itness and and the belief in
Talent to to be able to
to weather like that and and so now
when you go into acute pain as you have
experienced you are now naturally
addicted to whatever pain management
pain medicine they're giving you so
I've never been on on
rugs to but I had nerve damage and
structural damage in order for your
nerves to grow back it's like watching
paint dry or grass grow it it's not an
easy thing and I went through
traveling the world and there was a
brand new thing called stem cell
research back then and I tried to get
into trials all over the world I went to
Dusseldorf I went to China I was in
Japan I I went to Thailand I I was in
Canada I yeah I kept getting cut from
the front
and each neurosurgeon said
I've got I have these plates that are
going to be perfect for you it never
worked I get few silly like scar tissue
that would wrap around like a fusilli
Noodle around my spinal cord it was one
failed surgery after another
nerve blocks
blocks yeah like right you've had it all
so am I yeah so so and then and here I
am
in like 92 pounds taking
drugs having to be on Fentanyl patches
the the pain was on a scale of of 0 to
10 10 being natural childbirth my my
normal way of living for almost 17 years
was seven and a half
and yet I never gave up I always knew
that the most powerful muscle in your
body is your brain If I Could divert my
brain away from the energy of focusing
on pain
yourself
and but it was not a total appeal oh
yeah you know I Disappeared for seven
seven years a little like seven years
three months three and a half months
you know that's a long time to be away
from the business however I had the
biggest catalog so it was the biggest
catalog selling artist at the time with
my debut album so but
seven and a half years you know people
go away and stuff and I showed showed up
on a brand new show
called American Idol
and it was like you were it was like
yesterday they saw you here we are oh
yeah Paul it became well no it was it
was touted it's going to be the most
Velveeta Cheesy
show that's going to ruin the music and
just watching that show it I couldn't
stop watching it for years he became
like the Death Star like to every other
network if a Network dropped 50 in all
their ratings we still were like 100 you
know it's funny because
um when I was doing Smallville I
remember them saying oh well all our
other shows they were kind of tanking so
this is helping us Break Even I'm like
what it was just weird so American Idol
was that show you know the only thing I
think about is I remember like people
remember how nasty Simon could be of
course how sweet and lovable you are and
how laid back and cool Randy was I just
sounded like Morgan Freeman by the way
Morgan Freeman oh but you remember the
first day I met Anthony that's good
you're good but no so when I look back I
remember going what he's so mean like
I know he stuck up for you a lot too
what did he not what are you smoking I
thought I read somewhere where like when
I don't know like he stuck up with you
about the whole thing with the the guy
one of the contestants and he had your
back so he didn't have your back oh my
God I'm wrong I I guess you're watching
a different version so you didn't get
along with him oh it was like brother
sister kind of like when you say brother
sister are you the sugar coating it
because it was like half brother half
sister I don't really know you I can't
stand Satan yes Satan
um it was it was probably the most
difficult job
challenging job that I I've ever had in
my career every day when you were on
your way to work were you having anxiety
and stress because you had to deal with
that I'll tell you I started the first
season the first month going to therapy
once a week
when it was going eight times a week
there was something wrong